New York City officials are expected to
address safety concerns today
surrounding president-elect Trump's
penthouse security around the
skyscrapers creating quite a traffic
nightmare in a very busy Manhattan
neighborhood Charlie Rose's yes it is
Secret Service agents and New York City
police are working on how to protect the
building and the people inside Michelle
Miller is outside Trump Tower with a
look at the complex plans Michelle good
morning to you a good morning well what
a difference a week makes when I was
here right after the election the front
of Trump Tower here on Fifth Avenue was
lined with a row of heavy-duty
sanitation trucks filled with sand that
a presence has been tabbed down
considerably not sure if you can see the
police standing outside but they're
armed and ready and while they're there
it hasn't prevented the public from
accessing this building to say get
upstairs to the Starbucks no indication
if any of those stores will be closed
but we can tell you that some of those
ground-level floors may be adorned with
blast-proof glass New York's scenic
Fifth Avenue is becoming an obstacle
course how many days have you been
dealing with this
the election the security effort to
protect the president-elect Trump Tower
home doesn't stop with the barricades
checkpoints and officers outside the
entire skyscraper is posted with Secret
Service agents as law enforcement
officials come up with a long-term plan
to protect the building located on ritzy
Fifth Avenue according to a former
Secret Service agent the security will
focus most heavily on the floor
surrounding Trump's 26th floor office
and the penthouse he lives in with his
family
penthouse windows will be replaced with
bulletproof glass
the elevators below the office in
residence will be locked off and key
coated only certain agents and staff
will have access outside parking along
the perimeter of Trump Tower will be
heavily restricted there's also the
potential for a restricted traffic lane
and delivery's Lane on Fifth Avenue
background checks will be run on
building staff and potentially some
residents officers will also face
increased pressure with the approaching
holidays more than 5 million people will
visit New York this year between
Thanksgiving and New Year's these ever
seen anything like this before
in terms of the barricades you see
no but I mean New York's always crowded
well bomb sniffing dogs could also be
used in the garage below Trump Tower but
the US Secret Service is keeping their
options open on whether to increase
those restrictions Nora all right
Michelle thank you so much I think we
can say Charlie there's going to be
changes in your hood yes exactly I have
your ID at all time seed all right